if you want to go in the guys spaces if
you want to go into the bar if you want
to go into work if you want to go into
all these men's spaces I have no problem
with that but what I do have a problem
with is you going into the men's spaces
and then whining about the way men talk
and suing them later what up guys
welcome to the Jazz pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today I want to
talk about how women police language to
the point that we cannot communicate
anymore so just something I noticed so
women complain so this is this could be
a series called women complaining again
now guys just as a prerequisite this is
not me saying I am better than any woman
this is not me you know trying to put
women down but rather to really point
out what our true nature is and that is
to complain and just never be happy be
if left unchecked that's that's the key
if left unchecked so what I noticed in
the space is women will interpret things
emotionally before logically so what
I've noticed is phrases like and I mind
you I used to do this at one point and
then I realized so when men communicate
they really communicate to get the point
across so oftentimes women will say it's
how you say it in your tone so if I say
if I say that oh sorry guys wait wait
I'm gonna be a better swear all right if
I say if I say that lady is the way the
men will and if she's right there if I
say You're fat the way the men will
process it is they'll look and they'll
say is she fat and the way the women
will process it is it's how you say it
don't say it like that in your tone now
why do I think this is a feminine thing
why don't men do this too and yes they
do but typically it's for women so now
when you go into a guy's locker rooms
now I've never been in a guy's locker
room but there's a reason we have
phrases like locker room talk because I
think if women heard the way that men
talk in a locker room a lot of us would
go home crying we can't take it we're
not meant to communicate like that but
when you go into a woman's locker room
now it might be different than how we
talk in public but I mean there's a
reason women will call each other fake
instead of saying things to their faces
so what does that say this is a feminine
imperative this is a feminine point of
view and the problem with men nowadays
is they've been taught to always think
about the woman's point of view they
went to school where they were taught to
think about the woman's point of view
they're either in single mother homes or
they have a father that always thought
about the woman's point of view right
and that's how do we see this in society
we have happy wife happy life it's
cheaper to keep or even the idea of a
man cave or the woman has the whole
house and the man has his little cave in
the basement and even just the
reputation of marriage you know we have
phrases like women you can't live with
them you can't live without right
indicating that maybe we're not the
easiest to deal with so basically what
happens in the workforce and in any
industry that women go into is the men
will be working they'll be doing their
thing in either the gym the workplace or
whatever they'll have all these mail
spaces it used to be bars gyms and the
women will want the attention from the
men they'll think huh I need that
attention from those men so they got to
figure out a way in and once the women
get into the space then they go in and
say it's how you say it I don't like
your tone and then they establish H the
dreaded HR because think about it guys
are are men really gonna are they gonna
develop HR are the men really suing
people like that oh HR I forgot and
lawsuits human resources and lawsuits it
tends to be more of a woman thing so
yeah that's really the I want to show
you guys broken down so what we have is
so what we have is the men have a space
where they can hang out then the women
they say I want in so then the men say
fine Susie you can come in now this
applies to bars the supplies to work and
this applies to really anything so we
got guys the next step is whining okay
so then the women will complain and then
uh there's typical things so they'll
whine they'll say everybody's trying to
F me even though half the time Susie's
half naked too or they'll say
um they'll say they have Trauma from the
way men talk or like something at work
traumatize them so then they'll complain
um and then something is given to the
women to make them happy so either human
resources or look at money from a
lawsuit so my message to women is if you
want to go in the guys spaces if you
want to go into the bars if you want to
go into work if you want to go into all
these men's spaces I I have no problem
with that but what I do have a problem
with is you going into the men's spaces
and then whining about the way men talk
and suing them later that's my issue um
and so we really need to publicly shame
these women I'm so tired of these women
that are five sixes at Beth saying how
everybody's trying to sleep with them
ma'am ma'am
you got to at least be an eight for them
and it's true because a lot of times
when we say this women base things off
of how we feel so if a woman feels they
were trying to do that then essentially
they were we just have this tendency to
blow things out of proportion and it's
really not even our fault it's just how
we are but the problem is problem is
we've lied to women and men about the
way women are yeah so my my final
thought is women's please stop going
into the men's spaces and complaining
about the way men are and stop dressing
half naked and not expecting men to hit
on you at work
um I think we can all agree on this let
me know what you guys think maybe
Pearl's crazy all of these opinions are
our opinions nonetheless let me know
what you think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time